[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
this is Sky News at 10 our top story
former prime minister Boris Johnson
quits as an MP after being told he'll be
sanctioned for misleading Parliament
over party gate he says he is bewildered
and appalled describing the committee
investigation as a kangaroo court
mounting a political hit job
the news a shock to Westminster with
government whips given no notice of the
resignation we'll be live tonight in
Downing Street and the former prime
minister's constituency
also tonight the classified documents
which could send former US president
Donald Trump to prison
today an indict moves unsealed charging
Donald J Trump with felony violations of
our national security laws as well as
participating in a conspiracy to
obstruct Justice
the nurse accused of murdering seven
babies described as a calculated liar in
court after denying having an affair
with a married colleague
a message of defiance from the Israeli
Prime Minister in the face of a new
Iranian threat but he says we're going
to decapitate you what will I talk about
the method of our decapitation we're
going to destroy you the method of our
destruction
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's coming up
in our press preview from 10 30.
foreign
[Music]
the former prime minister Boris Johnson
angrily resigned as an MP this evening
bringing an end to a colorful and
tumultuous political career spanning
nearly two decades he stands down in his
Uxbridge and South ruislip constituency
after being told he would be sanctioned
by the Privileges committee for
knowingly and recklessly misleading
Parliament about parties in Downing
street during lockdown an excoriating
statement Mr Johnson said he did not lie
and took aim of what he called a
kangaroo court determined to find him
guilty we'll have more on what his
resignation could mean for his career
and the future of the conservative party
in a moment but first our political
correspondent Liz Bates has this report
Boris Johnson who nine months ago was
prime minister has quit as an MP
in a long angry statement he blamed the
Privileges committee that investigated
him over partygate on learning they
wanted to see him suspended for over 10
days which could have seen him kicked
out of the commons he stood down
branding it a kangaroo court he thrives
on the oxygen of publicity so what on
Earth he'll do next I do not know in
some ways I don't care but I do actually
because I care passionately about having
people involved in politics that are
decent and honest and honorable and
don't tell lies that is not that man
Boris Johnson it comes amid a standoff
with the cabinet office over their
handling of his covid Communications
that has seen him once again in the
spotlight
and his resignation on his list added to
the controversy with his old Ally Nadine
Doris denied a peerage also dramatically
standing down just hours earlier
something significant did happen to
change my mind and you know I'm not
someone who's going to go you know
blabbing out what that was immediately I
need to you know process a few thoughts
and things but um so yeah something
significant did happen to change my mind
and and I did do and I think it's for
the best I didn't want to cause a
by-election but
but you know I've got over myself
frankly in his statement he takes aim at
the current prime minister his record on
brexit and his party's lack of ambition
and things are about to get worse for
Rishi sunak with a by-election now on
the horizon that could inflict another
electoral wound on the conservatives
in the final line of his statement Mr
Johnson says he's going at least for now
a message reminiscent of his last words
in the Commons as prime minister hasta
la vista baby a reminder to his Rivals
he may be leaving Parliament but Boris
Johnson's influence on British politics
is not going anywhere Liz Bates Sky News
Westminster
well our Deputy political editor some
coats is in Downey street so just how
significant is this then Sam well I know
inside number 10 behind me they're
braced now for a weekend of yet more
turbulence another few days of
conservative psychodrama and they're
having to prepare for two by-elections
neither of which the conservative party
are certain to win one for Nadine Doris
mid bedfordshire seat the other of
course for Boris Johnson but even
despite all of that difficulty I just
wonder whether some inside number 10
think this the preferable path Boris
Johnson could have chosen to remain but
that would have meant seeing the
Privileges committee report come out and
his Tory colleagues having to decide
whether to vote for him and I can tell
you Anna from the conversations that
I've been having although there's a
vocal minority who support him I'm not
sure that vote would have been pretty if
he had lost that vote he then would have
had to face his constituents in Uxbridge
and given there's only a 7 000 majority
there he could have been slung out by
the constituents that he has served for
since 2010 uh and now since 2015 and
that would be a humiliating end to a
career that's already pretty checked and
even if he'd won that he would be
hanging around in Parliament with
probably no path to ever becoming Tory
leader again just an irritant a ghost at
The Feast for this prime minister and if
the Tories lose the general election uh
next year whoever succeeds Rishi sunak
so Boris Johnson decided to leave Eve
that enables him to write his own story
in a blaze of publicity with the
spotlight shining at him alleging that
he was thwarted by forces that were
anti-democratic I just wonder Anna
whether this outcome as Boris Johnson
goes off to make a lot of money and
doesn't face those humiliations I wonder
whether this outcome quietly satisfies
both Boris Johnson and the people in the
building behind me
Sam coats in Downing Street thank you
well let's cross now to the former prime
minister zarks bridge and South ruislip
constituency Rachel venables is there
um somewhat marginal seat majority of 7
000 now facing a by-election uh what
have voters there been saying to you
this evening Rachel
well I think a considerable amount of
shock here in Uxbridge yes it has been
throughout the country reverberating
through Whitehall and Beyond Boris
Johnson of course such a Titan of our
politics and of course he's a huge part
of the local politics here he's been the
mp uh foxbridge and South ruislip for a
number of years now but as you mentioned
a marginal seat so this will have Labor
certainly rubbing their hands with Glee
This is a seat they had an eye on even
in the 2019 elections so Boris Johnson
was able to squeak through with the
majority of more than 7 200 that means
labor seems to be in a pretty good
position going forwards this now a seat
of course a Battleground going to be the
source of a by-election now I'm here in
the Town Center on the High Street of
course it's a Friday night and many of
the people I've spoken to actually
hadn't even heard the news that Boris
Johnson had resigned they're just out
enjoying their evening but all of them
expressing shock at the idea that he
could step back appreciation actually
for many of the people I spoke to about
the work that he has done both this
prime minister and as a local Member of
Parliament and of course I think as
always when you have a member of
parliament who is seen on such a
national stage as Boris Johnson was as
prime minister and even after he left I
think people really do appreciate having
somebody like that ask their Member of
Parliament so so far so far just shock
and appreciation for the work that he
has done but I'm sure as the night goes
on and we get more reaction we'll see a
split in the voters and it'll be
fascinating to see what people think
going forwards into the by-election
whether they will stick with the Tories
or whether we could see labor opening up
a gap here and taking this seat is no
doubt they will be hoping to after that
shock announcement from Boris Johnson
that he is stepping down as NP
Rachel thank you
well plenty of political reaction as you
might imagine including from the
opposition here's what the shadow
attorney general Emily Thornbury had to
say
I think that Boris Johnson has brought
all this on himself
but you know it's a soap opera what the
public wants to know about is who is
going to look after their interests
who's going to be actually interested in
in in the cost of living in looking
after all hospitals in making sure that
we fight crime on our streets that's
what should be important not all this
nonsense not all this chaos and not all
this corruption
what an extraordinary statement from
Boris Johnson earlier let's take a look
in more detail at some of it he said I
have been an MP since 2001. I take my
responsibilities seriously I did not lie
and I believe that in their hearts the
committee know it but they have
willfully chosen to ignore the truth
because from the outset their purpose
has not been to discover the truth or
genuinely to understand what was in my
mind when I spoke in the Commons their
purpose from the beginning has been to
find me guilty regardless of the facts
this is the very definition of a
kangaroo court it is very sad to be
leaving Parliament at least for now but
above all I am bewildered and appalled
that I can be forced out
anti-democratically by a committee
chaired and managed by Harriet Harman
with such egregious bias
well let's bring in the Tory grandee
Michael heseltine now your reaction then
to this resignation Miss hasseltine
even in his
resignation statement he can't tell the
truth he isn't being forced out
anti-democratically a select committee
of the commons has decided to tell the
commons their views about his behavior
it is a committed check
with a majority of conservatives and it
would be the House of Commons that would
decide whether he should pay a penalty
not the committee
but the second and overwhelmingly the
most important issue here is that this
is now a vitally important mail in the
brexit coffin because what is lied about
brexit time and time again
Nigel farage has now admitted that
brexit has failed and the
unforgivable damage to this country that
has been done on the basis of those lies
is actually Incorporated in this one man
his departure is a nail in the brexit
couple
well in saying that you are actually
answering something he put in a
statement I am not alone he said in
thinking that there is a Witch Hunt
underway to take revenge for brexit and
ultimately to reverse the 2016
referendum result my removal is the
necessary first step and I believe there
has been a concerted attempt to bring it
about has there
oh
yeah it is preposterous to think that a
conservative Committee in the House of
Commons is seeking to redress the brexit
issue over the very serious allegations
that the Prime Minister lied to the
House of Commons
he has played his typical game he's
looked at the report he knows the damage
that it will create and so he has
decided to go and avoid the humiliation
of being censored by the Tories in the
House of Commons and possibly fighting a
by-election that he would lose it is
typical
um
manipulation of the events and we've
seen it time and time and again
when Boris Johnson announced his
candidature to become Tory leader you
know the announcement was that he would
be like a chair effectively in Downey
Street should he win why was the three
party incapable of ensuring that
happened there was a recognition that he
kind of needed support for this job
well the truth is that the prime
minister is immensely powerful once they
have got the job and boys Johnson was
extraordinarily skillful in appealing to
both Tory MPS and to a wider public with
the basic case that um economic problems
the stagnation in living standards was
because of our membership of the
European Union of the bureaucrats of The
Blob as it was called the BBC and all
these people who were identified in
order to persuade a narrow majority of
the British people that if they voted
for brexit the problems would go away
the truth is they haven't gone away
they're getting worse day by day that
anyone who knows anything about what's
going on in this country knows that
brexit is a disaster and the quicker the
truth is told to the British people the
better the chance that we'll restore our
relationship with your
how will people remember Boris Johnson
what is his legacy
his legacy is to have broken the
achievement of Victoria governance of
the second half of the 20th century
whether it was
or Margaret Thatcher
step by step they took us back into the
heart of Europe
and Boris Johnson in a
total travesty of the real world
fractured that Tory achievement
much indeed Michael hesselton there uh
Boris Johnson's statement went on to say
I am afraid I no longer believe that it
is any coincidence that Sue gray who
investigated gatherings in number 10 is
now the chief of staff designate of the
labor leader when I left office last
year the government was only a handful
of points behind in the polls that Gap
has now massively widened the statement
there of Boris Johnson excoriating as it
was in a number of directions we'll
certainly get more reaction to that as
it comes in
let's return to the case now of Lucy
leppy the nurse accused of murdering
seven babies described as a calculated
liar in court today after denying having
an affair with a married colleague She's
accused of murdering the infants and
attempting to murder 10 more at a
hospital in Chester between 2015 and
2016. Katarina matotsi reports
this was Lucy letby's last day on the
witness stand during which the
prosecution called the former neonatal
nurse a liar and a murderer the court
was told about social media searches
that Ms letby had done whilst on shift
at the Countess of Chester Hospital on
one occasion searching in quick
succession for the families of three
different babies she's alleged to have
harmed
the prosecution Barrister Nick Johnson
Casey said what was the connection in
your mind between those three people
they are babies who have died from being
seriously unwell Lucy letby replied Nick
Johnson said you were checking up on
your victims weren't you no the nurse
replied you are a killer who was looking
at your victims no
over 14 days Lucy letby gave evidence
answered questions and vigorously denied
all of the charges against her and over
that time the court has also been shown
text messages that the nurse sent to
colleagues saying that the ward they
worked on was understaffed and unsafe
she was also suggested to the
prosecution that raw sewage had gone on
to one of the nursery wards where babies
were being cared for and there was also
the suggestion from the prosecution
about a possible motive they say that
Lucy letby killed babies to attract the
attention and sympathy of a male
colleague on whom she had a crush
charges she vigorously again denies
today Lucy letby denied having an affair
with that same colleague who was married
but she agreed she did have an active
social life going out drinking with
former colleagues after her suspension
from the ward in 2016. it was a period
of time during which the prosecution
said she'd previously told the court her
mental health had deteriorated she was
isolated from colleagues and very alone
Nick Johnson KC said you are a very
calculating woman aren't you Lucy letby
no you tell lies deliberately don't you
no the reason you tell lies is to try to
get sympathy from people no to get
attention no
the court was also shown once more a
note written by Miss letby and found at
her home in which she says I am evil I
did this
this is how I felt at that time Lucy
letby said I could not see a future for
myself Nick Johnson replied you are a
murderer no I am not you have murdered
many children I've never murdered a
child or harmed any of them
in her final moments on the stand Lucy
letby told the court before all this had
happened before her arrests she'd had a
very happy life
the trial continues next week Catherine
evertotsi Sky News Manchester
president macron has visited the city of
anisee in the French Alps and has
praised Emergency Services after four
toddlers were attacked by a man with a
knife yesterday a three-year-old British
girl among the four injured was on
holiday when the incident took place in
a small Lakeside playground from anisee
here's Becky Cottrell
today many came here to let out their
emotions
thinking of toddlers targeted by a man
who brought a knife to a playground and
started stabbing those he found
[Music]
he had this to contend with a remarkably
Brave man who brandished his backpack as
a shield to fend off further violence
his name is enri a 24 year old who was
visiting anesee to see the cathedral
he's no longer just a tourist he's a
hero city is
um
thankfully the four infants and two
pensioners who were attacked are all in
a stable condition
some of them were visited in hospital by
president macron
he also met with police officers who
were on the scene and of course the
pilgrim turned man of the hour
Colleen Simone's granddaughter attends
the school opposite the playground that
was targeted when she heard the news of
the attack she feared her grandchild was
involved
record
is
a
um
the suspect has been named as Abdul
Massey H by French media a 31 year old
Syrian refugee who's been living in
Europe for a decade
we've spoken to people here who say they
saw the suspect in the months and even
days leading up to the attack sitting on
this bench near the playground looking
completely calm
terrorism is not thought to be a motive
for this attack this is a senseless
crime the violence and vulnerability of
the victims Beyond any reason or
understanding Becky Cottrell Sky News
anancy
former U.S president Donald Trump will
face 37 criminal counts when he appears
in a court in Miami next week he's
accused of mishandling classified
documents which he kept on leaving
office obstructing justice and making
full statements well that's because
several of the highly classified
documents some kept in boxes in his
ornate bathroom at his Mar-A-Lago Resort
showed sensitive information including
the weapons capabilities of foreign
countries details of United States
weapons programs potential U.S defense
capabilities or vulnerabilities and
details of how Washington would
retaliate if there was a foreign attack
well a U.S correspondent Mark stone is
in is outside Donald Trump's Golf Club
in Bedminster New Jersey mark
uh Anna it has been quite the 24 hours
of all the chapters in the Donald Trump
story and there have been many this one
is compelling for his supporters and his
detractors it is deeply troubling but
for starkly different reasons either he
is a crook who conspired to steal secret
documents or he is a victim of a
conspiracy to bring him down
spotted by Sky News on his golf course
at lunchtime a former president
preparing to be arrested we watched him
teeing off just an hour before the
extraordinary indictment against him was
unsealed for all to see
49 pages 37 felony counts federal
charges the potential of years in jail
if found guilty make no mistake this is
huge legally and politically
it is all about documents in these boxes
seen here for the first time some
classified some secret some top secret
seized by the FBI at last year's raid on
his Mar-A-Lago Resort now we know what
they related to
the classified documents Trump stored in
his boxes included information regarding
defense and weapons capabilities of both
the United States and foreign countries
United States nuclear programs potential
vulnerabilities of the United States and
its allies to military attack and plans
for a possible retaliation in response
to foreign attack
we know where they were stored these
unsealed images taken at Mar-A-Lago show
them in boxes in a bathroom in a
storeroom in a ballroom
then there is recorded evidence of Mr
Trump showing a document to others
saying he knew it was Secret
Trump showed and described a plan of
attack that Trump said was prepared for
him by the Department of Defense and a
Celia military official Trump told the
individuals that the plan was highly
confidential and secret Trump also said
as president I could have Declassified
it and now I can't you know but this is
still a secret
that last point is alleged to have taken
place here at his New Jersey golf course
in July 2021 months after he had lost
the presidency and crucially it appears
to contradict his defense that he had
somehow Declassified the documents it
appears to prove that he knew he had
retained secret documents
Jack Smith is the special counsel in
this case he tasked a grand jury of
ordinary Americans to examine the
evidence They concluded there is a case
for Mr Trump to answer
are laws that protect National Defense
information are critical to the Safety
and Security of the United States
and they must be enforced
violations of those laws put our country
at risk
adherence to the rule of law is a
Bedrock principle of the Department of
Justice
and our nation's commitment to the rule
of law sets an example for the world
we have one set of laws in this country
and they apply to everyone
Mr Trump's defense for now is deflection
a box is hoax just like the Russia
Russia Russia hoax and all of the others
this has been going on for seven years
that they can't stop because it's
election interference at the highest
level there's never been anything like
what's happened I'm an innocent man I'm
an innocent person top Republicans are
reacting this is hugely politically
charged Speaker of the House Kevin
McCarthy wrote I and every American who
believes in the rule of law stand with
President Trump against this grave
Injustice House Republicans will hold
this Brazen weaponization of power
accountable
it is the voters who will drive the
direction of all this remember he is Far
and Away the favorite to be the
Republican candidate for the presidency
and a trial may not conclude before the
election
his Republican opponents are siding with
him
I had hoped the Department of Justice
would see its way clear to resolve these
issues with the former president without
moving forward with charges
and I'm deeply troubled to see this
indictment move forward
it's important for all of us to remember
that no one knows the facts in this case
and As Americans
it's essential to remember
that you are innocent until proven
guilty
this will test America politically
legally socially The Divide will deepen
the split between those who want Trump
in court and those who believe this is
an attempt by Joe Biden to remove his
likely opponent rather than face him at
The Ballot Box brace for Jeopardy and
turbulence ahead
now we've not had any sighting of the
former president over the course of the
past a few hours I imagine that he has
been absorbing uh the indictment that 49
pages in the same way that we have it
was at 7 pm last night here that he
received a call from his attorney
telling him that he would be charged
that he would be arrested that he would
need to go to court in Miami uh next
Tuesday tomorrow he will fly from here
to Georgia where he will hold the first
of two rallies where his supporters will
gather in their hundreds I'm sure there
will be another one in the Carolinas
before he then heads to Florida to face
the music
thank you
well these federal charges add to a
growing list of legal woes after the
deadly attack on the U.S capital Donald
Trump could yet be charged with inciting
or aiding an Insurrection in March next
year he'll face a criminal trial over a
hush money payment made to a porn star
before the 2016 presidential election he
and his adult children face a civil
lawsuit in New York seeking to
permanently bar them from running
companies in New York state a trial is
scheduled for October this year and
prosecutors in Georgia are investigating
whether he and his election team acted
illegally to try to overturn his defeat
in the state's 2020 presidential vote
but even so his supporters stick by him
Martha Kellner has been speaking to some
of them in Florida
it may look tranquil but beyond the
Still Waters of Lake Worth Lagoon the
home at the center of a political
earthquake
Behind These Walls at his Mar-A-Lago
Resort prosecutors claim Donald Trump
violated the Espionage Act
he kept top secret documents they
claimed strewn across this house
flaunted papers they say which
threatened National and Global Security
when FBI agents arrived some were even
spilling over the floor
the legal Jeopardy is cranking up but
his support at least here is Resolute
you don't think that there's any
legitimacy in these charges about
violating the Espionage Act even no I
don't we know that he's very boisterous
and we know he's kind of a show-off but
he's an awful good president
this case is unlikely to reach trial
until after the presidential election in
2024 and Donald Trump Remains The Man
most likely to be the Republican nominee
if he is he'll be arranging campaign
rallies around court dates in two
separate criminal cases the implications
of this are extraordinary
he's staring down the barrel of some
serious jail time and I think that it's
finally starting to sink in just the
gravity of the situation and I think
that it would be in its best interest to
actually cut a deal because if he ends
up going to jail he's 76 years old right
now which means that he could ultimately
end up dying if he does have to serve
jail time so he could die in prison and
I'm pretty sure he doesn't want to do
that
at the local pickleball courts annand
Maureen hoped the game is finally up for
Donald Trump I despise the man I think
he's a crook I think he doesn't know the
difference between a truth and a lie I
think he's so egotistical and looks out
for himself and really doesn't even care
about
this country and it's amazing that it's
not going to change some people's
opinion of trump
that includes their friend Jackie I
think it's a lot of showboating
by the Democrats because they know he's
very popular and uh I don't think it's
going to change anybody's mind either on
either side
back in trademark Style
trying to Galvanize his supporters but
these challenges and the apparent way of
evidence against him will be difficult
to defend against Martha Kellner Steins
West Palm Beach Florida
or we return now to our top story Boris
Johnson's resignation as an MP with
immediate effect after accusing the
commons committee investigating
partygate of attempting to drive him out
to our Deputy political editor Sam kotes
in Westminster and out he is going a man
who wanted as a child to be World King a
modern day Churchill left now with what
Sam as a legacy
well it's interesting isn't it Anna that
Boris Johnson departs the front line
political stage claiming that he was
effectively undermined and slung out by
an establishment That Couldn't tolerate
him on the day that Donald Trump also
faces a very uncertain future and two
also is saying that he is being
undermined uh and by an establishment
that does not want him any chance of
returning to power now actually Anna I
think the comparisons between Boris
Johnson and double Donald Trump can
really be overdone but what is that
Legacy because I think it is quite a
substantial one you know what the list
of achievements Boris Johnson would give
winning the 2019 general election in the
face of lots of turbulence delivering
brexit getting the country through the
pandemic with the vaccine and then
stewarding the country again as the
Ukraine war took hold but but in some
senses Anna love him or load them I
think the legacy is much bigger than
that for I think that Boris Johnson
changed politics changed politics
potentially irrevocably he challenged a
conventional way of doing things whether
it was his attitude to international law
whether it was attitude to fellow
conservative colleagues who he slung out
of the conservative party whether it was
challenging the Civil Service ripping up
the rule book and relying on a
popularity to take on all of these
different institutions in a way that I
haven't seen at any point in the last 25
years of reporting Westminster and the
question is where does that Legacy leave
the country will the next prime minister
build on that or try and return to a
perhaps calmer way of governing but one
thing Boris Johnson has left the
political stage but he hasn't left the
national stage for good
Sam coats live there in Downey street
thank you
well that was Sky News at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
newspapers in the Press preview
including this story on the front page
of the mirror there it is no surprise on
their lead Johnson quits over partygate
shamed xpm resigns as an MP well tonight
we're joined by the Whitehall editors of
the guardian and the financial times
Rowena Mason and Lucy Fisher
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
well this is kind of used in just a
moment the Press preview a first look at
what is on the front pages first let's
get more reaction to our top story Boris
Johnson's resignation as an MP with
immediate effect after accusing the
commons committee investigating
partygate of attempting to drive him out
I'm joined now by the former chair of
the committee of standards in public
life Aleister Graham he's made it quite
clear he told the truth he did not lie
and that this is a whitewash what do you
think
well uh who can tell until we read the
Privileges committee report which we
he's had a chance to see but the rest of
us uh haven't you have to remember that
it was a unanimous decision to set up
the Privileges committee inquiry and
there's a majority of conservative MPS
sitting on that committee even though
it's chaired by Harriet Harman who is
the labor MP
um
I almost thought that he did mislead
Parliament during the time when it
became clear that uh there'd been
parties and Downing Street uh and
everything when he said the rules had
been maintained uh I suppose it's his
way of sticking two fingers up to the
Privileges committee but I personally
always thought he was a person who would
fight his corner to the last so I'm
rather surprised he threw him a towel in
we were just hearing actually that the
Privileges committee will meet on Monday
to conclude its inquiry into whether
Boris Johnson misled MPS and plans to
publish its report promptly following
the former prime minister's resignation
from The Commons that's according to her
spokesman uh promptly needs to be done
now don't you think we need to read it
for ourselves yes we do uh um and we
need to put this issue to bed I thought
he might try and fight and persuade a
majority of conservative MPS not to
accept any recommendation coming out of
the Privileges committee
but given as I said there's a unanimous
decision to set up this inquiry it's a
bit difficult then not to accept the
results of that inquiry
what should happen now do you think
well
given he's given up with an MP there's
going to be a tough contest in Uxbridge
his constituency
uh and uh
even the Nadine doroth seat with a I
think a majority of 24
who dwell given the current state of the
mood of the nation uh Mike will switch
to another political party so I think
we're going to have an intense period of
electroneering uh and uh we're going to
have lost some real entertainment from
the House of Commons
he's made some really critical comments
about members of the committee he said
they had made defamatory remarks about
him they had already prejudged without
hearing evidence should for example
Harriet Harman the chair of that
committee have recused herself as Mr
Johnson suggests
well he's going to put his argument out
but it's accepted by the House of
Commons uh who was on the committee
who'd chaired the committee
um so I'm not convinced by his arguments
that somehow he's had a shady deal in
terms of the Privileges committee he
gave evidence to it we all watched him
and he wasn't all that impressive in
giving evidence to the Privileges
committee and given the evidence
available I'm not surprised if they do
come to the conclusion that he didn't
know any mislead Parliament
Alistair Graham good to have you on
there uh thank you very much indeed for
your time thank you
[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
Press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages let's see what's making
the headlines then with the Whitehall
editors of the guardian and the
financial times Rowena Mason and Lucy
Fisher welcome to both of you on what is
a very busy day front pages then let us
kick off with the telegraph their
headline Johnson quits as MP over
partygate similar from the mirror which
calls Mr Johnson deluded for claiming he
was forced out
the express cites his claim of a
kangaroo court
those protestations from Mr Johnson are
also the main concern for the male I've
been forced out by a Witch Hunt the
paper says the star pictures him as a
clown proclaiming the party's over for
bozo
the times says
the party is over now
the Sun Splash is simple
Bojo I quit
the eye describes the former prime
minister as declaring war on his
successor Rishi sunak
and it's very nearly a full house as Mr
Johnson's departure is also the top
story for the guardian and as the lone
exception the financial times reporting
on claims of sexual misconduct at the
hedge fund ODI Asset Management
although Mr Johnson does make the front
page
well reminded by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages for
yourself of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us so let's go straight to Our
Guest then Rowena Mason and Lucy Fisher
welcome to both of you
um Lucy you kick off
um you know wow did this take Everyone
by surprise
uh in a word yes I think it's a move
that has stunned Westminster tonight
it's been quite a dramatic day
um firstly with uh Nadine Doris
announcing her shock resignation from
The Commons
um amid claims that she had been cut
from Boris Johnson's Original
resignation list because Rishi sunak
didn't want to spark a by-election that
he might be at risk of losing then of
course we had the resignations uh list
um of Boris Johnson published saw the
Allies he has decided to enable in the
gongs he's handed out and then of course
the real bombshell came at 8pm when
Boris Johnson announced that he was
stepping down in protest at what he
called a kangaroo court approached by
the Privileges committee that has been
investigating him we know that earlier
this week he was handed the draft
findings of that committee that has been
looking into whether he deliberately
misled the House of Commons when he gave
assurances that lockdown parties didn't
take place in downings during the
pandemic yes a kangaroo court a
political hit job a Witch Hunt it was
all out there and his fundamental belief
as he saw it in this in a massive
statement he put out Rowena was that
they knew he was telling the truth as he
saw it at the time and the inquiry of
course was whether he misled Parliament
he said he did not and he did not lie
that's right it's an extraordinary
thousand word quite um bitter and
combative statement from Boris Johnson
um it's got lots of Targets in it the
main one is the Privileges committee
itself this cross-party committee
um comprising a majority of tourists but
also some opposition MPS and he's saying
that they he he believes that they knew
hand on heart that in their hearts that
he did not lie and but have still come
to this conclusion
um according to the to the version that
he's seen that that he did mislead
Parliament
um and he's he's accusing them of
political bias because the committee uh
was chaired by a labor MP Harriet Harman
um and then another major Target of this
statement is also Rishi sunak's
government itself
um even though soon act there's no lost
love between the pair but sunak has
approved this uh resignation honors list
for Boris Johnson today a whole list of
peerages and honors for some of Boris
Johnson's closest allies have been
approved and yeah Boris Johnson has
really gone on the offensive in this
statement towards sunac he's uh
criticized him for betraying his legacy
his 80 seat majority that he won in 2019
and this whole list of um of other
failures on policies saying that he
hasn't made the most of brexit that he
hasn't cut taxes enough
um and that he's not running a
conservative enough government and then
of course by triggering this by-election
itself he's created a real headache for
zunak because his seat
um in in in in Uxbridge and ruislip is a
very difficult one for the conservatives
to win now and labor are really snapping
at their heels in that seat um and
similarly in Nadine Doris's seat of mid
bedfordshire as well so the prime
ministers had a a pretty bad day here
he's got a lot of problems piling up as
a result of Boris Johnson's decisions
I mean it's fascinating isn't it um his
statement I am now being forced out of
parliament by a tiny handful of people
with no evidence to back up their
assertions I believe a dangerous and
unsettling precedent is being said but
did it suit him Lucy to go do you think
we know he makes money on the speaking
circuit you know he can write we know
that as well nobody ever really saw him
as a backbencher
well look I think firstly um we can
pretty much
um assume from what Boris Johnson says
in his resignation statement that the
committee was going to give him a
sanction severe enough to have
potentially sparked a by-election anyway
so in part what we're seeing today is
him seizing the initiative in stepping
down on his own terms rather than having
to face a suspension from The Commons of
10 days or longer which would have set
in motion uh the ability of his
constituents to start a recall petition
and in turn to trigger a by-election to
oust him I think also we've got to look
carefully at what he said in this exit
statement which is that he's sad to be
leaving Parliament for now very much
an unveiled threat to Richie sunac that
he plans to return so we know at the
moment cchq is in the midst of selecting
candidates for for many other seats for
the general election expected next year
so it seems that Boris Johnson May yet
try and apply for one of those and could
still be a thorn in Rishi sunak's side I
mean to my mind as well where as Rowena
says by criticizing Rishi sunak's
leadership by
um keeping sensor on him for his
approach to all sorts of things from
housing to brexit to tax to trade
um it's clear that you know he thinks he
possibly did a better job as leader
himself and it may be that he still
hobbers Ambitions to try and return to
the Helm of the party at some point well
Daily Mirror a shamed xpm resigns as an
MP Johnson quits over partygate deluded
Tori claims he's been forced out after
seeing this Commons report uh yeah there
it is on your screen and the times as
well the party's over uh over now
Johnson quits as MP but that word for
now in the statement is fascinating
isn't it because he said three bites at
being an MP first standing um or
attempting to stand as a conservative
included South I think back in 1997
before finally becoming Henley MP Rowena
then obviously standing down after
winning uh the mayorship of London and
then um re-standing again in his current
or now not current constituency so you
know he's a man who sees opportunities
to come back
I mean he has had an absolute roller
coaster of a political career and
um one thing we've learned about Boris
Johnson is that he shouldn't ever be
written off he seems to bounce back from
from everything and being sacked on
multiple occasions
um and so this statement was as Lucy
says very intriguing in this this
statement that he's uh leaving
Parliament for now it's this hint that
he could potentially try to come back
um possibly before the next election
um but
in that event Rishi soon I can see chq
would have to approve him as a candidate
so that seems pretty unlikely but he
does it shows he still Harbors these
Ambitions he feels he's got unfinished
business and he feels there's this very
strong sense throughout the statement
that he feels he's been done this huge
Injustice
um and by being wrongfully removed from
um from his job in number 10. so it's
clear he wants to come back
um and I don't think we should rule him
off although this time he is extremely
unpopular with the public
um over his actions during the covid
pandemic the party Gate scandal um and
and other things since that led to him
being removed from Parliament and also
with conservative MPS there was of
course this opportunity in the Autumn
when Liz truss left for him to
potentially come back he was another
possible candidate against Rishi sunak
and he did not have as as much support
within the Parliamentary party as Rishi
sunak did so he he wasn't able to come
back then it might take a bit longer
than the next um year and a half until
the next election for him to be able to
rehabilitate his reputation at all in
order to be able to come back before
then yes and he he has a dig doesn't he
at uh those Tory MPS who seem to be
supporting effectively the opposition uh
you know who forced him out last summer
and as you said did not support him to
come back against Rishi sunak
um The Daily Mail as well um Lucia Boris
have been forced out by a Witch Hunt xbm
quits as MP with blasted a kangaroo
court this dangerous and unsettling
precedent claims a political hit job I
mean it's it's all in there it's the
whole it's the whole list isn't it but
in terms of his legacy you know he had
he had such great Ambitions for himself
and what he'd be like as a as a prime
minister you know what has he delivered
how will he be remembered and how did it
all go wrong from that 80 seat majority
it is
I I was going to say um that I think
it's in some ways um a little um too
soon to talk of Legacy because as Rowena
said you know we shouldn't write Boris
Johnson off he's made clear he has
unfinished business but I do think um
part of this um Angry lashing out that
we've seen in this um resignation
statement is a bid for him to try and
protect his legacy he clearly is furious
that Rishi sunak this week has finally
made clear frankly what anyone watching
closely has known for several years now
which is that the US has no interest in
pursuing a comprehensive free trade
agreement with the UK at this time and
he lashes out at Rishi sunax
Administration uh junking his plan to
scrap all EU laws within a certain time
frame and he hits out at um the sunak
administration's decision to shelve a
bill on Animal Welfare which as we know
is a particular cause that his wife
Carrie Johnson has championed so there
is this sense that Boris Johnson is
wounded that his legacy is being
unpicked by his successor in this way
yes and indeed the eye picks up on that
Boris Johnson declares war on sunak as
he quits Parliament listing some of
those things that Lucy just did Rowena
but also
um he threatens sunak with a future
return saying goodbye for now you know
it's like the uh the sword of whatever
are standing over him isn't it but um
well will we should soon not be shaken
by this do you think will this prompt
some sort of Civil War in the
conservative party or is the reaction
muted enough that Boris Johnson
um will will walk off into the sunset
with nobody cheering for him
it'll have taken him in the sense that
he's got these two incredibly difficult
by-elections that he could really do
without it's a lot of resources that the
party will have to spend and it's not
unlikely that label will win certainly
um in uh in Johnson City but possibly
even in this very safe seat in
bedfordshire as well belonging to Nadine
Doris and I think most conservative MPS
will be relieved that Johnson has gone
and they want to Rally round at their
party ahead of an election which is now
only just probably over a year away and
so
um
see that will be really happy that he's
no longer got Johnson in Parliament
however as we've seen from the last few
weeks and months Boris Johnson has this
Knack of being talked about he's been
talked about because of the Privileges
inquiry there's been fresh evidence
handed to police in relation to
um potentially unlawful gatherings in
checkers and Downing Street um from the
coven pandemic era he's he's just a
thorn in Rishi sunak's side and because
he's he's continuing to dominate the
political sphere in this way I think
soon act will suspect that he has not
seen the last of Boris Johnson yet that
there will be ways that that he'll
continue to criticize soon act from the
sidelines writing columns making
television appearances and speeches he
has not gone away yet
your byline on the front page of the
Guardian along with Aubry allegretti
formerly of this Parish I have to say uh
Johnson quits over reporting to
partygate the Daily Star as well the
party's over for Bozo Fibber claims blah
blah blah blah whatever their usual
humorous style and then the double page
spread in the times uh the story we
thought we'd be talking about which is
the gongs the hairdresser and all
um a reward for failure as the headline
puts it there Lucy
okay
yes so this is the contentious
resignation honors list that has been
the source of much wrangling between
um sunax advisors and Johnson's team in
recent months to get it over the line
um it's significantly pruned back as we
understand it uh from the original list
that Boris Johnson Drew up
um in order to keep it in line at least
in terms of the totals with previous
Prime ministerial resignation honors
list and for me some of the most
interesting uh gongs and period is
handing out are to people who worked in
Downing Street at the uh at the heart of
Johnson's operation during the party
Gate scandal and in particular
um a Gong handed out to Martin Reynolds
who has dubbed party Marty by the
tabloids for his role in organizing the
famous or inFAMOUS I should say bring
your own booze party in May 2020 during
the first national lockdown in the UK a
party that took place in the Downing
Street Garden
um there's also other
um notable uh
um nominees on this list um one that
caught my eye was Ben Houchin the
conservative mayor of teas Valley who's
facing a lot of questions at the moment
about the government's Flagship
regeneration project
and the other big story which we don't
have time for right now but we'll return
to is of course the News about Donald
Trump
um you know the front page of a number
of newspapers including the front page
of the telegraph Trump uh has been
charged with illegally keeping top
secret files relating to America's
nuclear weapons and foreign allies after
he left the White House he was also
accused of keeping a pentagon plan of
attack against Iran and highly sensitive
documents from both the CIA and National
Security Agency Lucy ruino we will see
you very shortly thank you both very
much indeed
lots of breaking news stories today
Boris Johnson resigning as nmp and more
of course on Donald Trump too
[Music]
foreign